and we are inside casa calavera a  mexican restaurant you know  i want to point something out so far  it's pretty authentic  i found my name on the wall hector and  my sister's name  carmen there you go so just on the wall  it's pretty authentic already this is  the entrance for this uh  restaurant the inspiration here is dia  de los muertos day of the dead and you  can see  we have a lot of that theme playing out  not just here in the  entryway but all across the restaurant  it's pretty neat and believe it or not  we are told  that this bar area this countertop is  just about a hundred years old that's  just one of the many things you can find  here